[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAUREN SMITH BRODY:
Hi, everyone.
And thank you so much to
Karen and to everybody
who put this together today.
And to all of you, the
catch-22 with my book
is that the people
who need it most
are often the
busiest, so thank you
for taking time out of
your work day to be here
and to share in the
collaboration of making things
better for new working
parents in the workplace.
So our talk today is
going to be about how
new parents can revolutionize
America's workplace culture.
So when I was expecting
my baby, my first son,
it was about nine years ago.
I was working at "Glamour"
magazine, a pretty supportive
environment, actually.
And I found that there
was a lot out there
for the first three trimesters,
which were pregnancy.
And then when I had my son, I
found there was a lot of advice
for the newborn phase
and for baby care.
And that continues on.
You learn how to
diaper your baby.
You learn how to potty train.
There wasn't anything
for going back to work,
and that was what I
desperately needed.
And I discovered that
there is actually
a whole other trimester,
a fifth trimester,
and it's when the
working mom is born.
So going back to work.
We're suffering
right now in America
from a crisis of
expectations for women.
In some ways, it's
served us really well.
We expect the best.
We expect we can do everything,
and often we achieve it.
However, it can bite
us in the rear end
also because we have all these
expectations of motherhood.
Motherhood is supposed to be so
beautiful and this incredibly
meaningful experience.
And of course it is,
but when we're not
supported in a larger
way by our culture,
it can also be
incredibly challenging.
So we hope the
transition to motherhood
will feel as if you're
meditating on motherhood.
And actually, sometimes it
feels like you're drowning.
And that is due to
a lot of reasons,
but primarily because-- and
this is better than most places,
here at Google--
but primarily because
you're just not
getting enough time
home with your baby
before you have to
go back to work.
I know that was my
biggest obstacle.
So when you look
at FMLA, which is
what we're offered by
the government, which
is 12 weeks of unpaid
leave, when you get into who
is actually able
to take that leave,
it gets really unavailable.
So the United States guarantees
12 weeks of unpaid leave
only if you've been at that
employer for one year or more,
if you work full time,
and if your company has
50 or more employees.
So once you do the math and
all the Venn diagramming of who
actually fits in that little
availability to have it,
you end up with only 56% of
working women qualify for FMLA.
That blue area on the
circle in front of you
is everybody who
doesn't qualify.
But then even of the
people who are qualified
to be able to take it,
I don't know about you,
but I don't know
that many moms who
can afford to not be paid
for a quarter of their year.
So many, many don't take it.
And what we end up with is
that 25% of American mothers
take two weeks or less
of maternity leave.
And then compounding
the problem,
let's look at that
12-week-old baby.
So I mentioned this idea of
the fourth trimester, which
was how I learned from this
book called "The Happiest
Baby on the Block," written by
a wonderful pediatrician named
Harvey Karp, who
establishes this phenomenon
of the fourth
trimester, which is
the idea that human
babies are actually born
a whole trimester too
soon because of the size
of the pelvis and the
size of the brain.
And so to soothe a newborn
baby, you swaddle that baby,
you shush them.
It's all these S verbs.
Anyone who's expecting a baby or
who has a baby in this audience
probably knows this.
But I remember reading that
book and finding it so helpful
and also so frustrating.
Because page after
page, he would say, just
get to 12 weeks.
Get to 12 weeks, and your baby
will wake up to the world,
they'll start to
get on a schedule.
They'll give
something back to you.
And I thought, oh, that's
exactly when I go back to work.
I also have to add--
back to those
expectations from before--
that when I was getting
ready to have my first son,
I packed my going
to the hospital bag
probably three months before
I actually went there.
And I included in it a
little going home outfit
with a giraffe on it.
I'd picked it out especially.
I really loved it.
And even though I had a
full 40-week baby born
at 6 and 1/2 pounds,
that little outfit
didn't fit him until
he was 4 months old,
which just gives you a sense.
And I'm the oldest of four kids.
I babysat my whole life.
I know what a newborn
baby looks like.
And yet still my expectations
were still so out of line
for what this tiny baby
was going to look like.
The other thing I
threw into that bag
at the very last minute
was my yellow work folder,
which was everything I
intended to do while in labor
at the hospital and
then over the course
of my entire maternity leave.
Thankfully, my employer
was understanding
and didn't actually expect me to
send any of that work back in.
But I thought I
should be able to.
So fast forward through
these 12 months of cranky
baby, who I'm shushing
and swaddling.
And we get to the end of
it, and even at 12 weeks,
that baby is not yet
on a nap schedule,
not sleeping through
the night, not
sitting up, certainly, not
eating anything but breast milk
or formula, and is starting
to smile and give something
back to me and be that
baby that I thought
I was going to give birth
to, who ended up not actually
being a real baby
baby until he was more
like three or four
months old, which
was when I was back at work.
So I discovered there's actually
this whole developmental phase
that is missing, and
it's the fifth trimester.
So looking at this
chart, you'll see
that 8.5 weeks is
the average FMLA
that most American women use.
12 weeks is the amount
actually allowed.
At 22 weeks-- in
my own research,
and I'll tell you how I
came about this research--
mom starts to feel
better physically.
At 24 weeks, she starts to
feel better emotionally,
and you can see what's
happening with baby
through the same amount of time.
But then of course,
look at that big chunk
of the fifth trimester.
She's been back at work by
then for much of this time.
So I realized there is this
whole missing developmental
phase, and I wrote a book.
In order to write
that book, I knew
I had to look beyond
my own experience.
Because my experience, to be
completely honest and candid,
was one of great privilege.
I had a supportive partner.
I was able to take a
couple of my weeks unpaid.
We saved up for it.
It was not a big problem for us.
We were able to hire a
caregiver in our home
who I really trusted.
And I knew I had to look
beyond my own experience.
Because if I felt
this desperate,
surely women who had less
support felt even more so.
So I decided to
do a giant survey.
It was national, and I
reached almost 800 moms.
And I asked them
all kinds of things
about their return to work
and about what worked,
what didn't, what was hard,
what kind of support they found
most beneficial.
Universally, they said
they wanted to help,
they wanted to
participate, they wanted
to offer the collective
wisdom that they had,
and I put it all
together into this book.
And I should also
note that these moms
were from all 50 states.
They were, some of them,
executives and CEOs
running their own companies.
Some of them were at
Fortune 500 companies.
Some of them were doctors
and lawyers and nurses.
Some of them were shift workers,
some of them were teachers,
some of them were
hourly wage workers,
and they also had
as many approaches
to motherhood as
I could think of.
So there were same
sex parents who
had carried the baby
and same sex parents who
had not carried the baby.
There were single moms, adoptive
moms, moms who use surrogates.
I really wanted to
see what do we all
have in common, and what
parts of our experience
can we pull from one another
to be this giant working mom
mentor.
I also interviewed
dads and partners
to see their experience
and to get their insight
into what maybe these
moms couldn't tell us
about themselves.
How did they see their partners
and wives dealing with it?
And then I did more than 100
long-form, hour-long interviews
to really go deeper.
And what I came up with
was a lot of solutions.
So we know.
We know from the
research and anecdotally
and from my own research
that new working mothers
need longer paid leave,
which positively impacts
employee retention, job
satisfaction, future earnings,
mom's physical health, mom's
mental health, and baby's
physical health, too.
The reason it impacts
baby's physical health--
and I am very much a
fed is best kind of mom.
However you feed your
baby is fine with me.
However, breastfed
babies are much less
likely to have ear infections
and respiratory infections,
and so they're healthier.
Mom's chances of having
a perinatal mood disorder
dramatically go down if she's
had six months of paid leave.
The six month number
keeps bubbling up.
It's really an important
support for new parents.
But they also need
cultural workplace shifts
upon their return to work.
They need support
from above and below.
from their peers.
They need the right
degree of communication
when they're out on leave.
They need a gentle reentry
plan, and I'll tell you
more about that in a minute.
And they need acceptance
of new boundaries.
So just to look
specifically at what
a great family leave
policy looks like--
and this is ever evolving.
Even in the year that I
was researching the book
and in the two years since
then, since it's come out,
things have changed
dramatically.
A good policy at
this point, and I
think it will continue
to be improved upon,
is inclusive, fully
inclusive, of same-sex parents
and adoptive parents.
It equalizes the time offered
to both women and men,
doing away with
this whole notion
of primary and
secondary parents.
It allows for
intermittent leave.
If you have two
parents, it allows
you to use each
other as a resource,
and one person can take their
leave a little bit later,
perhaps filling in as the
primary caregiver when
the original primary
caregiver goes back to work.
And it also offers hourly
and shift workers--
and we've seen this recently
happening at Starbucks
and Amazon--
the same paid leave that
their corporate colleagues
get as well.
So just to give you
a smattering-- and I
had 50 questions and hundreds
of data points, honestly,
but this is just a smattering of
what I came up with and guided
the advice that I
gave in the book,
but also guided where I
looked to for expertise.
Because I am actually
not an expert.
What I am is somebody
who is a journalist who
finds the right
experts and who finds
women who've been through this
who can offer their expertise.
So here are just
some statistics.
76% of the moms
who I surveyed said
they wished for a longer leave.
That's a good starting point.
71% of partnered moms fought
more with their spouse
during their fifth trimester
than they ever had before,
and that includes during
the newborn phase.
So even when they
were healing, they
were more able to
communicate clearly
than they were on the other
side of it, going back to work.
79% said that they spent one
hour or less per week on me
time.
This guided me
because this wasn't
a matter of how can I
find you more me time,
it's more like can we talk
to mental health experts
about how to you
reframe what me time is
and take more pleasure
in what you actually
do have to do with your day.
Because if I could give
you a 25th hour, I would.
Instead, I'm going to help
you try to see the time
that you have differently.
They reported, these
mothers, that their commutes
were 50% more stressful
after having a baby.
And this actually tied
back into me time.
There was a lot of
correlation between the two,
and how can you use what's
seen as lost time in your day
to actually be good to yourself.
They spent six minutes
each morning-- this is sad.
This is the point at which
somebody when I gave this talk,
started to cry.
They spent six
minutes each morning
simply enjoying their baby.
They actually spent
more time getting ready
than they ever had before but
less time on themselves, which
helped me realize that we
need to give advice about how
can you organize your closet?
Is organizing your
closet an important part
of going back to work?
It turns out it
actually is, so that you
can be more efficient, have
more of that time in the morning
spent actually
enjoying being a mother
for the bookends of
your day that you
do have with your children.
I came into this, I will
fully admit, somewhat biased.
I thought I was going to hear
from parents that those who
had bosses that did
not have children
were not as understanding
about the transition.
That ended up not
really being true.
Bosses without kids were
only 12% harder to please.
Again, this becomes much
more about introspection
and how we feel about ourselves
and how we project ourselves
in the workplace than
it is about the bad guys
doing bad to us.
Pumping is a really
big deal for a new mom.
81% of moms who pumped
said that work negatively
impacted their ability
to feed their baby,
and 32%, including this guy,
described being walked in on.
That's awesome.
[LAUGHS]
So in 2018, what does a good
work reentry plan look like?
Because we know that it's
not just about policies.
It's actually about people
being able to use them
and then being supported
in their reentry
when they come back.
So it includes a
phase back option.
And this is starting to happen
largely at law firms, actually,
is where I'm seeing it,
where employees are offered
full-time salary
for part-time work,
temporarily, just to
ease their way back in.
Because especially working in
a really competitive field,
like if you're in big law,
if you work at Google,
if you work in tech, going from
0 to 60, which is really more
like 0 to 80, can
be very startling
when you're already compounded
by having a sense of self that
has changed anyway and
certainly a day with a hard stop
that it may not
have had previously.
A good reentry plan
also includes access
to high-quality lactation
rooms with privacy,
hospital-grade pumps, and
the ability to work there.
This was really key.
Women reported
that it's not just
about the logistics
of being able to pump,
it's about that feeling
of the stigma of it.
Of feeling like, ugh, it's
just a break in my day
when my day is already
shortened by having
to get home to this child.
And you don't want to be
seen as a person who's
taking breaks when your
day's already shorter.
If you can work
through it-- and that's
not an option for everyone.
Some people actually
need to be in the zone.
But once you get
into the groove,
many women reported that
they could work through it.
So it's also about having
a thoughtfully set up
lactation room that
allows you to do work,
and then, this is really key,
exiting the lactation room
with that milk and then
basically announcing, casually,
that you did a bunch of
work during that time.
It's important.
They also need flexible work
schedules and locations.
And most importantly,
they need a culture
where employees
feel like they can
use every one of these
benefits with no stigma.
One quick note in my research.
As I said, I came into it
with some of my own biases.
I shouldn't even really
tell you what they all are.
So I did breastfeed my
babies, and I pumped for them.
We had a nanny in our home.
I'm very up front about that.
But with the
scheduling, it wasn't
going to work for
us to use daycare,
but I made sure to
interview a lot of moms
who did use daycare and
home care and all kinds
of other child
care I hadn't even
thought of because I wanted to
see what their experiences were
like too.
That's why I really came into
this deeper interviewing I did
after I did the surveying
with this idea of breastfeed
or don't.
Take as little or as
much time as you like.
This was surprising to me.
There was a breadth.
I talked about all the
different kinds of diversity,
there was a diversity even
among the women's ambition,
and it did not really
fall along economic lines.
There were women who worked
hourly jobs who were actually
feeling quite
ambitious coming back,
and there were women in very
high-level, high-paid jobs who
reported that they kind
of had a blip of ambition,
and they weren't so sure
about it all anymore.
So this was really
interesting to look at too,
and it helped me
check my own biases
about moms staying in or not.
Really more than
anything, I just
want new mothers to have options
in the workplace and agency
and to be able to make the right
decisions for their families,
absent a federal plan
that supports them.
So the other thing
that I realized
is that these women
could achieve change,
and they reported that they had
achieved change by leaning in,
certainly.
Love Sheryl Sandberg.
They leaned into their jobs.
They came back.
They moved up the ladder.
And they officially made
policy change from within.
But I also really,
really wanted people
to know that it counts
just to stumble.
It counts just to show up, come
back, talk about what's hard.
I'll tell you a story
about how this was actually
what inspired the book
for me in the first place.
I had been back for
a couple of months.
I was tired.
I definitely had
circles under my eyes.
I definitely had left
a lot of meetings
because I needed to pump, and
I was pretty vocal about it.
And after a couple of months,
a colleague, Danielle,
came into my office.
I had hired her a
couple of months,
maybe, before I went on leave.
We didn't know each
other that well yet.
And she said to me, I
just want to say thank you
for being so open and
honest about your motherhood
in the workplace.
And I thought, oh god,
have I been unprofessional?
I was a little bit
of a young manager.
I thought, am I doing OK?
And then she went on
to say because you've
shown me I can do it too.
You've shown me that it's hard.
There are problems to solve,
but that I'll get through it.
Thank you.
I know I'm going to
keep with it one day.
And that was eureka moment.
It took me years to
be able to dig in
and do the research
to be able to produce
this book and this movement,
but that stuck with me.
So yes.
Stumbling works.
Don't fake it till you make it.
If you fake it, nobody
knows there's a problem.
If you pretend
everything's OK, how
can you expect anyone to support
you and help make it better?
Be comfortable
being seen as a mom.
You have to bring
your parenthood
to the workplace for anyone to
know that your personal life is
important to you.
And what I really hope
is that by solving
this very visible personal
life problem of a pregnancy
or expecting a baby,
we will actually
be solving personal
life issues for anyone
with a personal life,
which is everyone, right?
Everybody has something in their
life they care about as much
as you care about that baby.
And by solving our
problems, that's
going to trickle over into
greater corporate culture.
And as I said earlier, you
need to broadcast successes
in spite of visible challenges.
This is something that
a maternal mental health
expert I talked to, a
psychiatrist named Christin
Drake, tells the mothers that
she works with, who she sees,
who are struggling through.
She role plays with them
how to go in and ask
for accommodations
in the workplace.
She tells them,
think contextually.
It is a unique situation
of the American mother
that we have to ad hoc negotiate
these things for ourselves.
We are left to our own devices
in terms of this planning,
but also, more important,
in terms of the judgments
we make about ourselves
in the process.
Recognizing that can quiet
the noise in your mind a bit
as you go into those meetings.
Your new working motherhood
is full of benefits
to your workplace and your
home, and that's recognized
everywhere else in the world.
We are assets, not
liabilities, and you
need to feel that and
negotiate with that in mind.
A word about mommy
guilt. Because I
will say, the one thing
that I actually invested
in and splurged on, as
I did oh, I'm a very--
I must do everything
myself kind of person.
The one thing I
didn't do is I didn't
transcribe my interviews.
I hired an awesome
single mom in Ohio
to transcribe my interviews,
and Sarah's the best.
Anyway, I'm so glad that she
sent all these files back
to me, and I could see that one
word popped off the page again
and again and again.
If you were to
make a word cloud,
guilt would be the biggest word.
Every single person I
interviewed talked about guilt.
Only guess what?
It meant different things
to different people.
Some people felt very
guilty for being at work
and leaving their baby in
the care of someone who
they felt was less
capable than they were.
Other people felt
guilty for enjoying
being at work, which led me
to think, as I was teaching
my son about
division, if you all
have the same
common denominator,
let's scratch it out.
Let's not call it
guilt. Let's call it
whatever the actual feeling
is and the experience
is so that we can solve for it.
So don't just write off
your motherhood experience
and the challenges
of it as guilt.
You've done nothing wrong.
And if all else
fails, be this lady.
And I think I'm going to have
a conversation with Karen.
Thank you, guys.
KAREN: As I mentioned, I
just loved your book so much.
So I want to read just a short
paragraph to the audience
to show you guys how spot on.
Especially for those of you who
have just come back from work.
It's at the beginning
of the book, when
you talk about what
it's like to come back
to work for working moms.
"In short, it's a mess.
The typical professional
mother in the United States
goes back to work very,
very sleep deprived.
She's just started getting
positive emotions back
from her baby.
She's about to experience
the rockiest period ever
in her relationship.
She has no free time.
Every three hours, her
body makes milk that leaks
onto her lovely work
clothes if she does not
do something about it.
And baby and body aside, she's
about to come back to a job
that other people
have been covering
for her with various degrees
of happiness and resentment
about that fact."
And it goes on.
It's just so good,
and it's so spot on,
and I feel like everyone
should read that.
Whether you're
working mom or not,
I feel like it's
really hard to express
what it's like to come back when
you just get back from work,
and people don't realize all
that you're going through.
So what are your
recommendations on how
do you even start that
conversation at work
without making people
feel awkward when you say,
I have to go pump, or this
is what I'm going through.
How do you start that
conversation in the workplace
and have it stay appropriate?
LAUREN SMITH BRODY:
Well, thanks.
I think first you
have to realize
that it's your discomfort
that makes someone else feel
uncomfortable.
And if you can sort
of flatly say, oh, I'm
going to go pump now,
like it's no big deal,
it gives them permission to
realize it's no big deal.
And maybe the first time
it feels like a big deal,
but the second and
third and 489th time,
it will not be a big deal.
The other thing I tell moms is
that when you're coming back,
you can feel less than.
You can feel-- and this is
not particularly PC to say,
but you can feel like you're
less capable than before.
The research actually
proves otherwise.
You are in many, many
ways more capable.
You're better at pivoting,
because that baby drill
sergeant has taught you that
you don't really need time
between activities anymore.
You can just turn on a dime.
You're better at
prioritizing your time.
saying yes to things.
You're better at
saying no to things.
You're more
nurturing, of course.
But when you come back to work,
you may not feel all of that
immediately.
Hopefully, if
you've read my book,
you will, you'll internalize it.
But the one thing you can
really know that you're doing
and be proud of is broadcast.
Broadcast the stuff that's
hard, and you will actually
be doing something positive
for your workplace.
You will be helping make
things better for other women.
And I hate to give anyone
a list of to-do's ever.
There really is
not a single list
of to-do's in the entire book,
but I would add this one.
Really try your hardest
to know that you're
going to pay a
little bit forward,
and you will reap the benefits
of the confidence that
gives you too.
KAREN: Yeah.
I cannot underscore that enough.
For those of you that
know me and work with me,
I'm pretty vocal
about this stuff.
One, I'm just a
generally open person.
But after reading
this book, I also
have been trying to be more
vocal about my experience.
And last week, I had
an executive summit
that was a full day meeting.
And because everyone on my team
knows I use the mother's room,
and I'm just back, and
I'm breastfeeding my baby,
somebody on my team said,
here's where we need to go.
Here's the agenda for off-site.
Here's the execs
that are coming.
And by the way, here's
the closest mother's room.
And it was a male on
my team that did that,
and I was so touched by it.
It really meant a lot
that of all the planning
of this big executive
summit, he took the time
to look up where
the closest mother
room was to the conference
room we'd be in.
And it really
helped me save time,
so I just underscore that.
And that's an
example that I've had
very recently, within
the last couple weeks.
LAUREN SMITH BRODY:
That's amazing.
That's great.
KAREN: So sleep deprivation.
LAUREN SMITH BRODY: Yes.
KAREN: I personally
have a baby at home,
and I have a 3-year-old toddler.
So I'm lucky to get four
hours of sleep in a row
these days between my
toddler waking me up--
he just has these
nightmares on occasion,
and then the baby
sometimes wants to eat
or wants a pacifier
or a little snuggle.
How do you recommend we come
to work and bring our best
self there when we're running
on empty with very little sleep?
LAUREN SMITH BRODY:
So this is really,
if you want to just boil
the fifth trimester down
to one thing, it is
about sleep deprivation.
The women who I surveyed told
me that they were, on average,
starting to sleep
seven hours straight.
Not consistently, but starting
to, at the seven month
postpartum mark.
So at that point,
they had been back
at work for many
months, most of them.
Everything else falls
apart if you can't sleep
and if you're not sleeping.
All of the other
advice, none of it
really counts as
much unless you're
getting a good night's sleep.
There's so many strategies.
Like everything
else in the book,
I didn't really think of it
from the baby care perspective,
because far be it for me to
tell you how to sleep train
your baby.
My six-year-old slept in
a sleeping bag on my floor
last night.
But what I can do is I decided
I could interview women who
are experts in maternal sleep.
So these are PhDs
who study sleep.
One of them also has
a side gig studying
the military's use of sleep
deprivation as a weapon of war.
She's awesome.
And they basically said--
so I'm not even joking you.
Every expert said,
oh, well, coffee's OK.
Which is true.
A little bit of coffee is OK.
But there are all
kinds of strategies.
It starts at home, certainly.
It starts, actually, with
parity in parental leave
and with being able to
lean on your partner
to take the nighttime shifts
at least as much as you do,
particularly if your
body is still healing,
and emotionally you're
still getting better.
What the sleep
experts said, it's
funny that you mention four
hours, because that is really
the minimum.
What you want to
do if you can is
take turns with your
partner, ideally
for two nights in a row,
but at a bare minimum
for two REM cycles in a row.
And that is
basically four hours.
It's 3 and 3/4 to
4 and 1/4 hours.
And that resets you enough.
If you are coming
back to work after two
nights in a row of not very
much sleep or fragmented sleep,
you are as impaired,
the experts told me,
as if you're showing up drunk.
And think of that also
for your work in the home.
If you're on maternity leave,
and you're home with that baby,
and you haven't shared the
night with your partner,
if you're lucky to have
a partner as a resource--
And I have to add, the
single moms I interviewed
were amazing for getting
through all of this,
but they also just
checked their egos
and dove into asking every
single thing they needed
from the people in their
lives in a way that all of us
should embrace.
But if you have that
partner you have
to share the wake-up
duties with him.
You have to think of your
job at home the next morning
taking care of a human baby
as the most important job
in the world, just as
important as your partner's,
who's going off to work.
KAREN: After you
get that sleep done,
my morning starts pretty crazy.
So I wanted to
ask you a question
about the transitional times.
Even on a good day, when I
get a good night's sleep,
my morning is
something like this.
The kids wake up
around the same time.
My toddler is yelling for me
or my husband to come get him,
and the baby starts crying
because she's hungry.
And we'll just kind of like keep
swapping of who is feeding who,
and who's taking care
of who, and who's
showering and getting dressed
and putting on makeup,
and it's chaos.
And then I leave in the morning,
as soon as the nanny gets
there, I'll give her
the baby, and I'll
run to go pump one more
time before I get to work.
And then I leave,
and my toddler's kind
of holding on my
leg, telling me he
doesn't want me to go to work.
And the baby, who should have
gone back to sleep by now,
is crying.
And I've probably been up since
5:00 or 6:00 in the morning--
LAUREN SMITH BRODY:
You've lived a whole life.
KAREN: I've lived a whole life.
And I stumble, and I'm like,
I just came out of a storm.
My hair is everywhere, and
I'm holding my pump bag
and my purse and my computer.
LAUREN SMITH BRODY: That
part gets better, I promise.
KAREN: And then it's 10:00
AM, and I'm just making it
to my 10 o'clock meeting.
So for me, my morning
is crazy, and I'm
assuming it's like that for
a lot of parents coming back,
especially moms.
How do you-- what are
your recommendations
for that transitional morning
time to not lose our minds
and get to work and feel
like we're ready to go?
LAUREN SMITH BRODY: So the
transitional times really,
in all of the anecdotal evidence
that I had from these women,
are by far the most
stressful parts of their day.
And it is because it is
the logistics that you're
describing, and it's also
that emotional feeling
of being neither here nor there.
You're not fully on
as a mom, you're not
fully on as a worker,
you're in between.
You should be spending
time on yourself,
but who has time to
spend on herself?
And it's really hard.
The thing that helps the most is
the thing that I was actually,
I have to admit,
the most hesitant
to include in the book.
My bias is that I worked at
"Glamour" magazine for years.
I oversaw a lot of the
fashion and beauty pages,
and so some of the
stuff I just know.
But there's this
thing that happens--
and this was always
sort of in me--
but when you have
a new baby, you
don't feel like
prioritizing this stuff.
It does not feel as important as
it may once have to you before.
instead of lipstick,
you have baby,
and baby feels a lot more
important than lipstick.
So what I looked at in my
research and with the experts
that I talked to was not
how do you look better,
it's how do you feel better
about the way you look,
and how to you compress
your time in the morning
to make it really efficient in
terms of impacting how you look
and how you present
yourself to the world.
So there are some
really concrete tips
that are things like for
your closet in the morning,
don't let your closet
be a torture device.
You shouldn't open the
door and see everything
that doesn't fit and think, is
that going to work with that?
I don't know.
You actually need to
make a miniature closet
within your closet of
the six things that fit.
If you see that you don't
have a pair of pants, by God,
go out and buy a pair of pants.
But then every morning, pull
just from that little section.
And you can add to it
as things start to fit,
or if you're going
on a work trip,
and you need different
kinds of clothes, fine.
But it just simplifies it.
And then in terms
of beauty, there's
a lot of wanting to cover
up under-eye circles.
And yes, concealer is great, but
the dermatologist I talked to,
who treats all these
celebrities and who
knows every trick in
the book, basically
said it comes down to
washing your face at night.
To make sure to take
that time to do that.
And drinking a lot of water.
And she just really
recommends more than anything
that you try to take good care
of your skin in those ways
because then you'll need
less makeup in the morning
to feel good.
And all of the research--
I was so hesitant to
include some of this stuff--
but all the research
really proves
that when you're back at
work, the way you look
affects how people think of
you, but it's also largely
because it affects how
you feel about yourself,
and you project that.
Like it or not, you do, and
it really has an impact.
KAREN: One thing
I noticed for me,
and you also mentioned
this in your book,
is that when you're
pregnant, it's visible,
and everybody at work
takes extra care.
Oh, you can't, I
totally understand,
you have a doctor's appointment.
That's fine.
But you get more of
that sensitivity.
Versus when you come back to
work after having the baby,
it's almost more stressful.
Well, it definitely
is more stressful.
But people don't see you
physically pregnant anymore,
so they just assume you're
fine, and you're back
to your normal self.
So how do you think about how
we should speak to our managers
about that, and what we ask of
them, and what sort of advice
do you have on how to talk to
our manager about the needs
that we have when it might
not be as apparent for them
to have the same sensitivity
as before we left.
LAUREN SMITH BRODY: So this
is a really, really important
question.
Because for a lot of women, this
is the first big negotiation
they do, both at home
and in their careers.
And if they do it well, and
they get what they want,
it fuels them to ask for things
in the future that are also
going to propel their careers.
And I don't really talk
about happiness in the book.
It's really going to
propel their satisfaction,
because that's what I
think is really important.
So there are some very specific
tips about negotiating.
So first, the earlier in
the process of having a baby
or expecting a baby that
you ask for this stuff,
the easier it is to
have that wish granted
and the easier it is
to feel like you're
contributing to the
greater whole at work.
And you never know exactly
how you're going to feel,
but if you come back
after having been away,
and you suddenly
then want to adjust
your hours, your
flexibility, whatever
it is, it can feel like a
sloughing off of duties,
and you're asking people who've
been filling in for you to give
you even more leeway.
Instead, if you can,
you want to really try
to anticipate, pretty much
as soon as you announce
a pregnancy or that
you're expecting to adopt,
how you envision
your job changing.
And you may renege
on some of that,
and you may rethink some of it
when the baby actually comes,
but it allows you to not
just get rid of stuff,
but actually train the
people around you who
want to grow up into some of
it, and makes you feel like
and be a good manager.
It also then frees you
up to think, what am I
going to fill this time
with now, now that I'm not
going to be traveling
three times a month,
and I have the person
I've been working
with who I've trained
to go out and do
that outward facing stuff,
what can I fill my time with?
And often it's bigger
picture thinking
and it's bigger projects.
And the other thing is whenever
you're in a negotiation,
obviously, manage up.
You want to think about
what are the-- you're
going into the conversation
with a plan, not an ask.
You really have to
tell yourself that.
This is a plan for
how it's going to work
and how you think of things
in terms of deliverables.
How you're going to
still do your job
and deliver your job
that you get paid for.
And then the other
thing that I heard
from a lot of women
that's incredibly helpful
is to ask for it temporarily.
To say, hey, can we
please just try this?
Because what that does is
it just keeps your manager
from feeling like they're
signing in blood that you're
allowed to do this forever,
and by the way, then setting
a legal precedent that they have
to offer this to everyone else
too.
It allows you to try it, see how
it's going, adjust on the fly
as you're going.
And then if you've set it
up as a two-month check-in,
three-month check-in, you go
back in, and you have a baby.
You know, baby needs change, if
not by the week, by the month.
And you can come back,
and you might actually
have other needs at that moment
that you can renegotiate for.
And it becomes much more
of a conversation that's
ongoing that will serve you
as your children's needs grow
and change too.
KAREN: Absolutely.
That's really helpful advice.
I'm going to take some of that--
LAUREN SMITH BRODY:
I wish I had had it.
KAREN: --for a couple of
things I have on my mind.
I want to circle back on role
models and peer mentoring.
While I do that, if
anyone else has questions
from the audience, you guys can
start lining up at the mics,
and we'll take questions
from the audience.
So here at Google, we do have
pretty generous maternity
leaves as compared to other
companies in the United States,
and even so, there's
still guilt--
I'm going to just use
that word for now--
about taking the full leave.
And I've had countless people,
even on my team, come and say,
I don't know if I should
take my full maternity leave.
I have so much going on.
Or maybe I don't need that
month before I go out.
And I remember thinking
the same thing,
even though I've told
everybody on my team,
no, you have to take it.
This is an amazing benefit.
You're going to want the time.
And I remember, when I was
taking my first maternity
leave, I said, I don't need
to take the whole time,
not knowing what I
was getting into.
And my boss, who was a male at
the time, said, absolutely not.
You're taking your whole leave.
And he told me to take
it, and I tell everyone
on my team to take it.
But I said-- and I was
a director at the time--
I said, I haven't seen a lot
of other directors taking
the full maternity leave.
Is that something I should do?
Because there's so many
people depending on me.
And of course we're
all replaceable,
but I just felt like I didn't
want to let anyone down.
And he said to me, well,
you are the role model.
You are the one that
has to take your leave
and show all the other
women and men that they
should take maternity leave.
And I just think that whether
you have a role model,
or we're doing peer
mentoring for each other,
it is really important
to set the precedent.
And is there anything
else you want
to share with the group on how
we can do even more of that?
We can announce
what we're doing,
we can encourage each other,
but if there are other tips,
I think that's what will
give us all strength
to ask for things that we need.
LAUREN SMITH BRODY: I
just couldn't agree more.
I really just could not
agree more with you.
Like I said, I really tried
to check my own biases.
And I did, I was compelled
by a number of women
who had their own businesses,
worked for themselves,
and had to take a very
short amount of leave,
whether it was a day,
two weeks, I understood
where they were coming from.
If you were working, though,
at a corporation that
has policies that other
people at various levels
are going to be using, even if
you're not at the tippy top,
you have to show the people
around you, beneath you,
and above you that this is
a problem worth solving.
And worth is really
the key word.
You have to show
that you're worth it.
I think the absolute
best way that we
can solve this problem
is by establishing parity
for what's available for dads
and what's available for moms,
same-sex couples, whatever
your approach is to parenthood,
you should get and you
should take the same
as the people around you.
Because the message that
gets sent otherwise--
and I'm just going to be binary
about this-- but if dad takes
far less leave than mom
takes, what dad is saying
is I'm more important at work.
And more important at work
translates to dollars,
and it gets into
all the other things
we're talking about
in our culture
right now about the pay gap,
about the motherhood penalty.
It's real because of this.
The other thing that gets set
up when you have unequal leave
is that mom, especially
if mom is like us,
and a woman who is packing her
bags three months before she
goes to the hospital,
mom wants to be
an expert at being a parent.
And dad probably does too.
But if mom is home with
baby, and dad is off at work,
mom is turning
this into her job.
Rightly so.
I certainly did this, and I
understand why everyone does.
You want to know
everything about it.
You're googling everything,
and so you become an expert.
But then when you
go back to work,
and you and your partner get
home at the end of the day--
again, this is assuming sort
of a typical work schedule--
guess who knows how
to do everything?
You.
Dad doesn't.
Even with the best intentions
in the world, when you first
got together, and when
you talked about how you
planned on parenting together.
If you know everything, he
doesn't know everything, A,
he doesn't know how
to do it, B, you're
going to have a
harder time trusting
him to learn how to do it.
And if you're coming from
different workplaces, of course
you may just have different
options offered to you.
One solution is for the partner
to take intermittent leave.
So when mom goes back
to work, actually
have dad take a chunk
of leave then and be
home with the baby for a month.
It allows the baby to
get a little bit older
and less vulnerable being left
in a non-family member's care.
It also lets that second parent
really be in the muck of it,
get it, understand it, learn
these things, and then for mom
to see, hey, look
who handled it.
It wasn't me.
This is great.
And there's actually
research that
shows that for every month of
paternity leave a dad takes,
mom's lifetime earnings
increased by 7%.
There's even research that
shows that paternity leave
impacts dad's relationships
with their children
when they're teenagers.
It's really pretty incredible.
KAREN: That's great.
Lauren, thank you so much.
Let's take some questions
from the audience.
LAUREN SMITH BRODY: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much for
coming and talking to us today.
I'm actually about to head out
on my second maternity leave
next week, and I really
appreciate all this advice.
So the challenge that I'm
facing is while emotionally it
was harder for me to leave
my baby, physically it was
actually easier to get
ready in the morning,
because he was still a blob.
And breakfast didn't involve
a spoon and all these things
and clean up.
And so it was easier.
I looked better in the
beginning because I
could take a little bit
more time for myself
and just play with
him and look at him.
And now that I have a toddler,
I have a two-year-old, that
is a way more demanding
sort of like contact sport,
it feels like.
And so I was curious what your
10th trimester looked like.
What your second fifth
trimester looked like.
LAUREN SMITH BRODY: Yeah.
I'm in my 30th one
now, and it is--
bigger kids, bigger problems,
but they can communicate.
So that's the big difference is
that your older child will now
be able to--
for better and for worse--
communicate their needs
and listen to your
directions, too.
I actually found I
was really helped
by being pretty deliberate
about how I used the time that I
had on my maternity leave.
As I said earlier, we
had a nanny in our home,
and we were able to keep
her employed and around
while I was on
maternity leave, which
was a privilege and a luxury.
But what that allowed
more than anything
was for me to take
special time with my older
child between nursings.
Usually it was about 90
minutes every afternoon
where I would take him
out to go do something.
And I felt, like
everything else about this,
it's about kind of pinching
yourself and reminding yourself
that you are doing this
good thing that you planned,
that you were capable of doing.
And so it gave me
time with him alone.
Because my worry going back was
I was not just going to feel--
I did feel better
about leaving the baby,
because I'd done it once before.
I was going to feel terrible
leaving this child who
could now ask me to stay.
And so I really-- he was
only three years old,
but we talked a lot in that
time about why mommy works,
because I didn't want him
to get used to the idea
that I was just
going to be home.
And I actually-- I was
lucky to work in a magazine
where I could show him the
pages of what I was working on.
And I remember there
was a bunch of awards
that we were giving out
to college students,
and some of them were
inventing all kinds
of amazing cool technology, and
so he really related to that.
And so for a year,
he would just say,
oh, my mommy makes a
magazine about women
who put clouds in the sky.
You know.
But it helped me so much
to feel like I was, yes,
the transition in the morning
was going to be messy.
I was going to have
yogurt on my shirt.
And if you plan for that,
you have an extra shirt
at your desk, if you can.
But I felt so much
better and so much more
full of purpose and meaning
being able to communicate that
to him.
I think it goes a
long way for the child
and for the parent
and to help you
get through the mess
of those early years.
And it does get
easier, I promise.
AUDIENCE: OK.
LAUREN SMITH BRODY:
[CHUCKLES] Did that help?
I don't know if that's
specific enough.
AUDIENCE: No, it did.
LAUREN SMITH BRODY:
You don't want the baby
to get short shrift, yes.
Well also, so that baby--
guess what that baby has?
That baby has a big sibling.
That's amazing!
The first kid didn't
have one of those.
I'm the oldest of four.
I would love a big sibling.
So you have to really
remind yourself
that what you're giving is
a whole family experience.
And somebody asked me once why
I didn't use the word "balance"
more in the book than I did.
And it's like I think
the word "balance" is
used maybe twice in 352 pages.
And I said, it's because I
don't feel like anybody should
feel like they're a fulcrum.
You shouldn't have to
like tighten your core
and stand like this.
You should be able to lean way
in toward work sometimes, which
is just the nature of
the work that we do.
I know it's the nature
of a work that you do.
And you should be able
to lean way into family
sometimes, and not only just
when you're on vacation.
There may be times
when there's something
going on with your kid that
requires your full attention.
And so it's also giving yourself
the benefit and the grace
of the long-term
perspective and saying--
I'm even-- I'm
kind of ridiculous,
but I will even actually
put a date on my calendar
every three months,
seasonally, as a check-in
of how has my balance been?
Do I feel like yes, this
week was really work,
and this week was really kids,
but overall, does it feel lined
up the way I want it to be?
And I found--
I like to control things--
I found that
control of something
that seems out of
control really helpful.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
LAUREN SMITH BRODY: Sure.
KAREN: OK.
Question over here.
AUDIENCE: So thank
you for being here,
but also thank you
for all of the work
that you've put into this.
Because what I can
honestly say is you
were able to put
data points together
to help explain emotions and
feelings that when you're
going through them as a
new mom or a second mom
or as a mom with a second
baby, third baby, et cetera,
you don't fully understand.
Your husband will ask you,
well, how are you feeling?
And you're like, I'm
sad, but you can't really
say why you're sad,
or you can't really
explain why you're
over emotional,
you just kind of are.
And I think everyone
goes towards hormones,
but there's other reasons
as to why you're sad.
So as I was reading
through the book,
there was one quote that
really stuck with me,
and I sent it to my husband.
So the truth is we expect
more and more from mothers
without giving them
any more support.
The result is you
have mothers who
think they should
be able to work
and have babies and
find that magic balance.
So I found one of the balances.
And then it says, the
result is every mom
feels like she's failing
and falling behind.
I mean, you go through your
highs and lows, but I will say,
as a new mom, most
the time, I really
did feel like I was falling
behind in the mom department.
So I sent that to my
husband, and his reaction
was what's your opinion on it?
And I said, it's 100% true.
No, no, no.
It's 110%.
Wait, it's 200% true.
And his response to me was, hm.
H-M-M-M-M-M. So he can't fully
understand what I'm going
through all the time, and
I completely respect that.
But my question to you is I
felt I connected very much
to your book, but I
want to understand
how can I help my
husband connect
to some of the
topics in the book
so he has a better understanding
of what I've been through,
because I don't think I do a
very good job of explaining.
I'm very much the fake
it until you make it,
until I have an overload,
and all of a sudden,
we're in a huge fight.
LAUREN SMITH BRODY:
Oh, we sound similar.
[LAUGHS] Thank you.
Thank you for reading
that part of it.
Well, it's funny.
There's so much I've
actually learned
since I've written the book, in
the speaking and the consulting
that I've been doing.
And a woman at a
law firm recently
told me, she was like, I've
got to share with you exactly
what I did, because it worked.
And she's amazing.
So before she went back to
work, after having her baby,
she got really, really concrete.
And I think I mentioned
that this book does not have
very many to-do lists in it.
So she made not a to-do
list, but a what it
takes list every single
thing that goes into not just
child care, but who's managing
the paperwork and the bills
in the house, who's
remembering people's birthdays,
and got really
granular about it.
And she told her husband
she was doing it,
so it didn't come
out of left field.
And then she said, I want you
to add everything to this list
that you can think of.
And she had thought
of most of it.
He added a few things.
I think she was glad that
he had some things to add.
And then she said,
let's make a time
and sit down together
and go through it
and divide it up evenly.
And you did have--
it takes work.
You have to assign a time
to each of the things.
But the act of doing it feels
so empowering that even if you
waver from that list,
and maybe you're
doing the laundry one
night instead of him
because who knows why,
the fact that it exists
is something to come back to.
And the fact that from
the very beginning,
you've established that a
lot of this is in your head,
this is the mental load problem,
and not necessarily in his.
Getting it on paper is
really good for both of you.
So that's one tip that
I've taken from a reader.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
KAREN: Let's go with
one more question.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
so much, Lauren.
And I just want to
echo what Heidi said.
It's awesome to have
you here, and thank you
for putting all
of this together,
so us busy working
moms don't have to.
LAUREN SMITH BRODY:
It's my pleasure.
AUDIENCE: The question I
have touches on something
that you spoke about just
briefly, motherhood debt.
So I took my maximum
amount of leave,
because it was given
to me, and I should.
But returning to work has left
me feeling like I'm behind,
and I'm now scrambling
to take on as many things
as I can to get back
ahead, which then puts me
in a feeling of being
completely overwhelmed.
And I'm wondering if you have
any thoughts or perspective
on that that you could share.
LAUREN SMITH BRODY: Well,
I do think some of that
can be handled
industry by industry.
I can't remember
if I mentioned this
when I was talking about
the post-leave things
that companies can do, but
there is so much, especially
if you're working in a
bonus-driven business,
in a business that
has commission,
in a business with
billable hours,
where it's just so quantifiable
what you've missed out on.
And I think that needs to
be accounted for somehow
in the leave policy and in
the benefits policy that
come around having children.
Anytime you can put numbers
and dollars to something,
it really does help, and you
internalize that value as well.
But some of it is just
hard, and some of it,
it just takes time
to get through.
I will say-- this is
going to sound kind
of counter-intuitive-- but one
thing that a lot of women told
me has helped them is--
and again, I don't want to add
anything anybody's to-do list.
But when you come back,
if you can do something
to help one of your colleagues
who doesn't have children
or who might have grown
children and is not
near this phase of life
anymore and tend to something,
do them a favor,
tend to something
in their personal
life, and you'll
feel so good, first of all,
that you were able to even
think beyond your own little
bubble of need right now,
which is very real, but
it also sends a signal
that this is not
just a uterus issue.
This is not just a
having a baby issue.
This is a greater personal life
need issue in the workplace.
And it also just sends
this message that yeah,
you caught that ball for me
for some time while I was out.
I'm going to be here to catch
it for you too if and when you
have a parent who gets sick.
This is just about being a
good person in the workplace
and bringing that
goodness to work
and helping it fuel
the work that you do.
And so that can
feel really good,
to feel like you're doing
something for someone
else in that moment, too.
KAREN: Let's take
one last question.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank you.
I just have a question
about the language we
use to describe parental leave.
I find myself even doing
this, but saying, oh,
Google has a really
generous leave policy.
And I think that undermines
the business value
side of why we do it.
This isn't just because you
want to be nice to new moms.
So I was wondering if you could
offer some alternative language
to use and also maybe share
some of the business-side value
that a company gets from
providing something like this,
other than [INAUDIBLE].
LAUREN SMITH BRODY:
I love this question.
You're so right.
It's not generous, it's humane.
Because it is actually kind
of the baseline standard
in every other developed
country in the world and even
in a lot of developing
countries, too.
So yeah.
I'm going to change my
lexicon in that way too.
It's humane leave
that's given here.
So I think the best
thing that you can do
is to think the way
you're thinking about how
you express this transition.
Sorry, tell me again the
second part of your question.
Oh, about the value.
OK.
AUDIENCE: So I think even
different than it being humane,
but it's also like Google
is doing this because they
are benefiting from it as well.
LAUREN SMITH BRODY: Yes.
Absolutely.
So there are studies.
There are plenty
of studies, and you
have to look internationally
to find them, unfortunately.
Well, that's not totally true.
There's good studies
in California
that show that business has
not suffered and has actually
improved.
And this was surveys
of business owners
since they implemented
paid family leave,
but their paid
family leave is tiny.
New York state, of
course, just unrolled
its first phase of paid family
leave as well, which is--
the way it's set up is
a model that is actually
almost identical to
the Family Act, which
had been proposed for years
and years on a federal level.
And so my hope is that if
it succeeds in New York,
and if we see it rolling out
reasonably over the next--
it's from now till 2021--
that it will have
greater national impact.
But to find real data about
what the value of this is,
you really have to
look internationally.
So Norway is ranked consistently
the happiest country
in the world.
It also has a huge percentage--
I wish I had it on
the tip of my tongue,
and I don't-- of not
just working moms,
which can be a little bit
of a misunderstanding,
but full-time working moms.
Huge percentage of moms
in Norway work full time.
They have incredibly
humane benefits
around parental leave for
both the mom and the dad.
And then when you look at
the economic side of it,
actually, their GDP
average per capita
is the highest of, I think,
the 18 top-developed countries
in the world.
So you have moms and
dads who are home
with their babies
for this vital time.
They are staying
in the workforce
in a full-time capacity
and then contributing
to their countries' economies.
That's really compelling.
The other thing that I
like to tell people about
is a study that was done
by KPMG for Vodafone
when they were trying to
look at their policies
in all their countries.
And they're not a huge presence
here in the United States,
but they're very big in
Europe, in particular.
And they looked at the
value of offering, it was--
I want to get this right.
It's six months of
paid leave-- maybe
it's 16 weeks of paid leave, but
then also this gentle re-entry
plan of paying for, I think, six
additional weeks of full-time
pay at part-time
work upon return.
And they found, when
they did the math on it,
that it would save-- if every
private company in the world
did this, it would
save $19 billion
in money that is lost
from people leaving.
Retention is
incredibly valuable,
and also it doesn't even put a
price on the reputation boost
that you get from having
these humane policies.
So it's retention, it's
recruiting, it's reputation.
All of that, if you
can put a dollar amount
on that in any way, it makes
a really compelling case
when you ask for what you need.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
KAREN: Thank you.
Well, Lauren is going to
stay and sign some books.
We have books in the back.
And you guys should
all read this book.
It's amazing, life
changing, totally relatable.
And Lauren, thank you
so much for coming
to chat with us at Google.
What a treat to have you here.
LAUREN SMITH BRODY: Thank you.